water and Sun that never came up to you
a boxful of the price of a donor
I'm they come from almost everything
a hundred men for every dog
become - feels like these so rich such
as the magical irrigation there's no end
to the Buffy's Institute but they
go to the lettuce fields and what
do they find Filipinos and Mexicans do the
work or the work is hard and Filipinos are
Mexicans are strong and can do it better
in the shed they might find a job there
but whether it's in the sheds or in the
field it's like a machine and endless
down on the Rio Grande on the Mexican
border Mexicans mostly do the one many
of them children there pays 40 cents
good pay for a day down on the rear end
and here women get the word and glad they are
together lucky to get a day two days worth a
week lemon who had land and a roof to cover
them one from one of the greatest migration
his hands keep moving even in his brain
he fixed his picking fee